hey how's it going guys mkbhd here and
today we have an unboxing and first
impressions of the sold out everywhere
asus e-pad transformer prime we're just
going to call it the transformer prime
so first things first we're interested
in what comes in the box here so right
when we take the top off here we got the
transformer prime looking mighty fine it
also has got some stickers on the front
and that boasts our awesome specs but
let's go ahead and uh take this to the
side just for a quick second and we're
presented with our literature nice text
says e-pad transformer prime looks like
we've got some more literature about the
unit which is always nice to read uh and
right behind that we have our microfiber
it's not complete without a microfiber
that's always nice and we also have our
usb charging cable and it'll come with
the wall ac adapter for the united
states which is where i got this guy so
of course you guys know right after this
i went right on ahead and unwrapped it
took it out the plastic fired it up and
put it into honeycomb and set everything
up real quick so let's go ahead and take
a look at my first impressions of the
transformer prime all right so now you
guys have seen what comes in the box so
it's time to take a look at the star of
the show itself the transformer prime
and i'm starting on the back here
because we're taking a look at the
hardware first and it's uh it's a pretty
solid uh tablet when i first took it out
the box i was like dang this thing is
light and it is super ridiculously thin
like pencil thin uh it's a metal back
it's an eight megapixel camera here on
the back
uh and we'll go ahead and flip this
around to the beautiful front where we
have that 10 inch ips display at
1280x800 got a 1.2 megapixel shooter on
the front on the right is our three and
a half millimeter headphone jack and on
the left hand side is a volume rocker
mini hdmi a micro sd card slot and our
microphone so let's go ahead and fire
this thing up and again this is first
impressions so i haven't really had much
time so i can't tell you know battery
life or durability or anything but first
impressions uh in three words are oh my
god this thing is so fast very
very responsive and i'm going to give
credit to the one gig of ram and the
nvidia tegra 3 processor that powers
this bad boy this is beautiful widgets
by the way very purity um
the tegra 3 processor is a quad core
processor so if we're running you know
heavy apps i'm not saying the browser is
heavy but anything that we run that's
heavy is going to be significantly
faster i think this marks the end of the
spec war and trying to have the highest
amount of specs i think if we put a
tegra 3 in everything uh we shouldn't
have any more problems and we can focus
on software now so what asus has done is
there's a tiny little overlay but uh
this is way more snappy than the tegra
2. all right this is running honeycomb
which is android 3.2.1 so i can go ahead
and show you that if you want to see an
about tablet there you go android 3.2.1
honeycomb and it's got a little bit of
asus overlay so you can exit out of
running applications so if we really
want to
all i gotta say is this tablet is super
fast
and i'm loving the thin form factor the
bezel doesn't bother me at all
the camera on the back hasn't been all
that bad either in fact it's uh the best
much better than the zoom that i was
using so if we go ahead and well i don't
want to take a macro shot there it's a
little bit extreme but uh you get the
point there's a pretty decent 8
megapixel shooter on the back
all this information and more will be in
the full review these are our
pre-installed applications from asus not
too bad if you ask me i really don't
mind we have this huge resizable myzine
widget so uh there you go that's a
pretty cool looking limo by the way i
like the look of that but again finger
response everything is exactly in tune
with the way it should be
on a tablet this is in my opinion the
most responsive
and awesome android tablet experience i
have ever seen so stay tuned to the
mkbhd channel for the full review this
has just been a quick first impressions
uh thumbs up if you guys like this so
far i'm really excited to see where this
goes either way ice cream sandwich
january 12th really excited mkbhd
signing out peace
you